[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
okay
epson projector yeah it's a straight up
projector projectors are not cheap man
that that projector probably has to be
at least like seven hundred dollars yeah
that's a great yeah that's a great thing
to steal
y'all went too far with this diabolical
random and insane
trend i have ever [ __ ] seen
[ __ ] kids are stealing the most
outrageous [ __ ] from their schools this
kid decided to steal a [ __ ] hand
sanitizer from the bathroom this kid
somehow ripped off a whole ass handrail
from the ground
one kid stole the whole bathroom star
the whole bathroom
oh and it gets better somehow this kid
stole the whole [ __ ] white board
this kid stole
the [ __ ] urinal like like how the
[ __ ] do you do this like i don't think
they're faking this like this would be
pretty [ __ ] hard to fake like i think
they're actually doing this [ __ ] that'd
be so funny you unscrew that from the
wall in the water just
gushing out hitting the mirror
stealing a urinal is crazy that's pretty
wild
online on our website for those who are
participating please know that when we
do catch you we will discipline you to
the fullest extent and you will be
arrested and you will be responsible for
any of the monetary damages that have
been done
again
this needs to stop
you'll pause it
you know what's hilarious about this
what
you get caught and you get arrested and
you go to court
the judge reads your file all right so
you stole a urinal as a prank
i'm not gonna [ __ ] put you in prison
for stealing a year yeah yeah they're
gonna be like that's
honestly pretty funny yeah it's just
gonna be like
all right so you stole a urinal
i'm sorry stole
a urinal
that's pretty good
all right first question i want to ask
is how'd you do it
really all by yourself and you took it
to the trunk wow
that's just damn impressive son
i'll do community service for five hours
what the [ __ ] can they do you will be
disciplined to the fullest extent i'd be
bricked up if i heard that oh
[ __ ] voice like i'm 16 years old and
that like her voice isn't bad yeah just
free you'll be disciplined to the
fullest extent and you will be arrested
i think i stole the urinal
cut to me one of those tick tocks the
kids getting arrested against the wall
[Laughter]
damn teach
now you're just doing that in her office
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
arrest me ask me come on arrest me
no don't
i'm too young to go to jail
actually get arrested for stealing the
urinal you look at the principal you're
like will you wait for me yeah yeah yeah
will you be here when i get back
yo prince
hold it down for me
[Laughter]
what else did they say
unfortunately we have had to close the
purple bathroom
for the boys that means that the blue
bathroom and the green bathroom for boys
are open for the rest of the day however
because of the antics of a few
we don't have soap
in any of the boys restrooms in blue
which means
dispensers so
you will not be able to thoroughly wash
your hands
please make sure you use the hand
sanitizer that is inside
of each of the common areas
god damn dude being a teacher sucks
there will be consequences you dirty
dirty no soap having boys
okay you feel bad about that too is one
of those kids is gonna put that on his
mixtape
yeah
and also the color-coded bathrooms
that [ __ ] that sounds like a strip club
yo prince you wanna know stole the
journals
come see me in the blue room
knock it off
enough
i can't imagine being a teacher and like
walking in the bathroom
it's just the water spring from yeah
yeah exactly
no
you like accidentally touch you know
some
urinal water on the way in or something
like that you go to wash your hands
what no
oh what
you just like touching the wall you're
like what
oh
what [ __ ]
then you just oh soap you [ __ ] then
you back up to lean against the stall
and there's no wall there and you fall
just straight back
and it hits the toilet you just can't
cuss
in all the urinal water
[Music]
god damn it yeah that is
really messed up man
so messed up what's this one
[Music]
was that a pay phone
it took the exit oh no
come on man jesus christ this [ __ ] had
me crying i saw this one
how has no one ever thought to do that
that's a pretty good prank do that to
someone in the club yeah oh my god dude
take someone's shoe in the club and then
just go back out in the crowd and huck
it
that's real men and [ __ ] like that's not
cool
unfortunately someone has to take a shoe
in the head in that scenario i guess you
don't have to huck it you could just
drop it somewhere
yeah
it's walking around
with a thin business sock
on the [ __ ] dirt
what happened to your what happened to
your shoe
someone stole it
i was trying to take a shaking [ __ ]
because then they have to admit that
they were sitting taking a [ __ ] at the
club i was taking a clump how yeah
how did they steal your shoe
weren't you walking like how would they
ever yeah i was walking
i was walking and i was just walking
slow
but how would they do that though i
don't understand the logistics you know
i don't know like i was i just i looked
away for a second
and then they took it up like with your
full weight i was taking a [ __ ] okay i
was taking this [ __ ]
just now you're taking a [ __ ] in the
club
it's like 1 30
a.m
tequila dude it just i have a fast
metabolism
i have acid reflux like my stomach's
upset
are we funny to do like coordinate two
guys and do both shoes oh damn it
damn it that is so mean
[Laughter]
when all these kids get to college
they're gonna be this childish still yep
now at a college club if someone goes to
take a [ __ ] they're gonna have to be
[ __ ] like this
[Laughter]
legs up against stirrups man
that's how i was gonna do the next
ping-pong shot
i was gonna fart it out of my ass that's
what i was saying
that's what i meant
[Music]
all right what's this one oh i saw this
one
oh my god so stupid bro
he filmed the kid's face i know and then
posted it it's fine all those teachers
don't know how to find this [ __ ]
jesus christ
two weeks into college demoniac
[Applause]
that is so [ __ ] up
am i alone
i'm asking you like you know you're
gonna be disciplined to the fullest
extent am i crazy for that no
i don't think so i had a teacher named
miss dick did i tell you that yeah i
think i've told you that before
no yeah
what did she teach
she like used to be a stripper i'm
pretty sure oh
she taught english
miss dick d-y-c-k ah and she was hot as
hell of course oh my god of course
seventh seventh grade eighth grade damn
eighth grade
two yeah
it was crazy yeah
you